bien chers collègues nous avons
l'honneur d'accueillir aujourd'hui
Monsieur Nicolas Schmitt commissaire
européen à l'emploi et au droit sociaux
monsieur commissaire européen je vous
souhaite la bienvenue et je vous
remercie de vous être rendus disponible
pour répondre aux questions de notre
commission d'enquête qui poursuit un
double objet d'une part
identifier l'ensemble des actions de
lobbying menées par uber pour pouvoir
s'implanter en France le rôle des
décideurs publics de l'époque et émettre
des recommandations quand concernant
l'encadrement des relations entre
décideurs publics et représentants
d'intérêt et d'autre part évaluer les
conséquences économiques sociales et
environnementales du développement du
modèle uber en France et les réponses
apportées à apporter par les décideurs
publics en la matière sans surprise
votre audition s'inscrit dans cette
seconde optique contenu de l'émergence
de nouvelles formes de travail entraînée
par l'émergence des plateformes
d'emplois notamment entre le travail
indépendant et le salariat que le montre
l'évolution de la jurisprudence de la
Cour de cassation en France sur ces
sujets et les discussions en cours
niveau européen sur lequel nous voulons
vous interroger sur le projet de
directive relative à l'amélioration des
conditions de travail des travailleurs
de plateforme d'emploi nous
souhaiterions aujourd'hui que vous
puissiez témoigner du rôle et du travail
de la Commission européenne sur ce
projet de directive récemment amendée
par le Parlement européen avant
l'ouverture du trilogue pourriez-vous
notamment nous rappeler les différentes
options envisager lors de débat
l'élaboration de ce projet directive sur
le statut de travailleurs des
plateformes numériques pourriez-vous
nous préciser les principaux points qui
ont été débattus à la commission puis au
Parlement européen ainsi que les
principales positions des différents
États membres en vue du prochain Conseil
européen en tant que commissaire
européen avez-vous été témoin d'action
de lobbying de la part des plateformes
pour orienter les choix de la Commission
dans le cadre de l'élaboration de cette
directive ces actions de lobbying
sont-elles comparables celles qui ont
été révélées par les Hubert-Félix qui
d'ailleurs je le précise touche non
seulement la France mais bien sûr tous
les grands pays européens et ainsi que
que Bruxelles je vous remercie d'avance
pour la qualité de vos réponses qui vont
aider bien sûr à orienter
les conclusions et les recommandations
que notre commission d'enquête pourra
rendre notamment dans le cadre
d'ailleurs de ce débat en France sur la
question de la directive je rappelle que
cette audition est ouverte à la presse
et qu'elle est retransmise en direct sur
le site de l'Assemblée nationale avant
de vous laisser la parole Monsieur le
Commissaire je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblés parlementaires impose aux
personnes auditionné par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vais donc vous inviter à lever
la main droite et dire je le jure
merci monsieur je vous laisse la parole
bien d'accord merci beaucoup
de m'inviter à cette commission et c'est
un grand honneur pour moi de m'adresser
à vous sur une question qui en effet est
une question capitale notamment pour
l'avenir du travail mais aussi contenu
de l'impact de l'économie des
plateformes sur le marché du travail les
conditions de travail et sur l'économie
en général on a vu ces derniers temps
ces dernières années les plateformes se
développaient de manière très rapide et
notamment la pandémie de covid 19 a
accéléré cette tendance nous constatons
que notamment sur les plateformes sur
site on a beaucoup vu se développer les
plateformes de transport de livraison
mais il y a de nouveaux secteurs qui
voient apparaître
ce type ce modèle économique que ce soit
dans le secteur du nettoyage
la santé de la construction de
l'hospitalité etc donc c'est un modèle
qui qui se développe rapidement alors
simplement quelques chiffres dans
l'Union européenne on estime que plus de
28 millions de personnes déjà effectuent
des travaux par l'intermédiaire de
plateforme alors pas que des plateformes
sur site mais aussi des plateformes en
ligne et donc
il y a un nombre important et croissant
et on pense qu'ils vont être dans
quelques années plus de 40 000 donc il y
a un besoin pour
effectivement
encadré le développement de ces
plateformes et il a il faut être on
n'est pas à la Commission des pattes
contre les plateformes les répéter très
souvent la Commission veut simplement
assurer primo que le travail sur
plateforme
assorti des mêmes droits même protection
sociale que le travail
en dehors des plateformes ça c'est le
premier élément c'est un critère à la
fois social mais c'est aussi un critère
de concurrence loyale parce que vous ne
pouvez pas avoir d'un côté des modèles
économiques qui
en quelque sorte ce sont libérés de une
série de règles de loi en matière de
droit du travail ou de protection
sociale et qui sont concurrence avec
d'autres types d'entreprises ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième bon qui
découlent du premier c'est que
effectivement tout cela pose problème du
statut de ce qui va pour ou sur une
plateforme et nous avons constaté que il
y a un grand débat dans beaucoup d’état
membres dans l'Union européenne en
dehors de européenne et je donne
toujours l'exemple de la Californie qui
finalement a inventer un peu le système
des plateformes ou finalement il y a eu
une loi d'ailleurs
essayons de régler cette question du
statut avec bien sûr un retour notamment
d'une grande plateforme qui a donné
d'ailleurs son son nom à au phénomène
quand nous parlons d'ubérisation et qui
ont essayé effectivement d'annuler cette
loi alors en Europe nous avons plus de
300 décisions administratives et
judiciaire concernant le statut des
travailleurs des plateformes alors la
plupart
vont plutôt dans le sens de placer les
travailleurs des plateformes comme des
employés en fait et non pas comme des
indépendants encore que pour les
plateformes à peu près 90% des
plateformes considèrent qu'il
trois personnes et que les gens qui
travaillent pour elle sont des
indépendants et donc les différentes
cours y compris en France un cours de
cassation ont en général statué en
faveur du statut d'employé même s'il y a
quelques quelques autres que d'autres
cas donc ça pose d'abord à l'échelle
européenne le problème d'une certaine
harmonisation puisque dans un pays une
plateforme peut opérer sous le avec le
statut de d'indépendant dans un autre
dans un autre pays elle fonctionne où
elle est obligée à
embaucher des des employés des salariés
donc il est important d'avoir une
certaine forme d'organisation d'un côté
mais surtout aussi avoir plus de
sécurité juridique et d'ailleurs c'était
toujours pas des arguments à l'attention
des plateformes
vous courrez un risque énorme d'être
confronté chaque fois un cas devant les
juridictions et donc ce serait mieux
d'avoir plus de plus de sécurité
juridique ou vous savez que le Parlement
européen c'est aussi saisi de la faire
avant notre proposition de directive il
y a un rapport d'ailleurs qui a été
préparé par Madame Sylvie Brunet une
députée européenne française du groupe
d'ailleurs Rio et qui a beaucoup inspiré
la directive la directive européenne
alors un mot sur la directive elle est
finalement le centre même le coeur de la
directive c'est la question du statut de
la personne travaillant pour ou sur la
plateforme de clarifier de mieux
identifier de mieux définir ce statut
et nous avons donc
introduit l'idée d'une présomption mais
d'une présomption réfractable d'abord la
présomption c'est de dire
a priori s'il y a contestation c'est la
remise en cause il y a une présomption
que la personne qui travaille sur la
plateforme et un salarié
mais pour définir cela nous avons
identifié un certain nombre de critères
nous avions retenu parmi les critères
identifiés je crois qu'il y en a 7 et il
fallait remplir au moins deux d'abord là
maintenant les discussions au Conseil
ont un peu ou un peu dans un autre sens
parce que le Conseil élargit le nombre
des critères et augmente le nombre de
critères qui devrait être rempli pour
que effectivement présomption soit
activée la présomption
c'est la plateforme si elle n'est pas
d'accord avec un éventuel reclassement
de la personne elle peut aller devant
une instance par exemple
juridictionnelle pour remettre ça donc
on a aussi dans le système une inversion
de la charge de la preuve celle qui
était actuellement du côté du salarié
présumé elle passe maintenant du côté de
la plateforme alors c'est un élément
très important parce que je sais très
bien et comme que les plateformes jouent
maintenant à un rôle important aussi en
termes d'emploi mais je n'accepte pas
réellement cet argument puisque si une
plateforme correspondent à un vrai
besoin dans l'économie des assemblées de
cas et bien elle devrait aussi pouvoir
fonctionner en respectant d'abord le
droit du travail donc la définition de
salariat
et des droits qui vont qui vont avec et
on peut trouver des formules et
d'ailleurs un certain nombre d'États
montrés et les plateformes certaines
plateformes le démontrent également on
peut combiner un certain niveau de
flexibilité
qui est important dans le fonctionnement
la plateforme avec avec aussi un certain
nombre avec les droits normaux je dirais
du salariat bon un deuxième élément
important de la directive c'est
effectivement
l'algorithme la gestion algorithmique
qui d'ailleurs est inhérente même à la
plateforme il n'y a pas de plateforme
sans algorithme et là la directive
introduit un certain nombre de nouveaux
droits qui sont à mon avis extrêmement
importants pour les plateformes mais qui
devraient aussi s'impliquer de façon
plus large au monde du travail puisqu'on
voit que maintenant de plus en plus
d'entreprises en les algorithmes dans la
ressource dans la gestion de leurs
ressources humaines et donc il faut
veiller à ce que cette gestion
algorithmique ne remette pas en cause là
aussi un certain nombre de droits en
matière de travail et en matière de de
transparence et de protection sociale
donc
maintenant un mot sur le Parlement le
Parlement a modifié légèrement la
proposition d'acquisition et avec une
majorité
relativement importante ils ont adopté
le rapport un rapport dont qui qui est
absolument
rejoint
l'esprit de la proposition de directives
de la commission aux modifiant un peu la
présomption puisqu'il est tendent et la
renforce ils enlèvent en quelque sorte
aussi des critères qui étaient
nécessaires à la définition de la
présomption il est réintroduisent
dans dans une deuxième phase quand il
s'agit de reclasser donc là il y a un
une modification du Parlement par
rapport à notre proposition alors un mot
sur les discussions au Conseil
bon là nous ne sommes pas encore arrivé
à une orientation
commune une orientation générale au sein
du Conseil on a failli arriver en
décembre dernier et puis ça ça
échoué et
les pierres que le Conseil essaye un peu
de d'affaiblir d'affaiblir la directive
notamment
l'aspect présomption de la directive il
y a des états qui sont plutôt réticents
sur
cette approche en matière de présomption
et je ne vous cache pas que j'ai un peu
l'impression que la France fait partie
de ces états-là puisque la France
propose en quelque sorte une dérogations
assez large par rapport à cette
péjonction qui poserait un problème
majeur puisque en quelque sorte elle
viderait d'une certaine manière la
présomption de son centre et et là aussi
de son efficacité
la présidence suédoise est en train
maintenant de négocier avec les États
membres avec l'objectif de parvenir un
compromis en juin il y a quelques sortes
de blocs qui freine et ceux qui jugent
que il faut pas trop s'éloigner de la
proposition de la Commission
pour ne pas précisément vider la
directive de son sens et de son
efficacité et donc il y a un pays un
grand pays de l'Union européenne qui
présente ne prend pas de position
qui pose aussi un problème parce que à
la fin il faut arriver à une majorité
qualifiée c'est un grand pays un très
grand pays mais le plus grand en termes
de population et donc
on travaille maintenant sur ce compromis
au conseil pour que après on puisse
aller
dans les trilogues pour trouver un
compromis après avec le Parlement un mot
sur sur les contacts vous savez que
chaque proposition de la Commission
avant de d'être élaboré ou avant d'être
présenté fait l'objet d'une très large
consultation
consultation de toutes les de toutes les
parties concernées donc il était clair
que on a eu un grand nombre de
consultations avec les plateformes
personnellement je peux vous dire que
j'ai rencontré une voir en ligne une
fois physiquement le CIO de
aussi de la fameuse plateforme qui fait
maintenant l'objet de notre de votre
commission d'enquête nous avons eu un
échange il a essayé de me présenter un
certain nombre de ses arguments
notamment sur la nécessité de la
flexibilité
ça n'a pas
changé notre optique parce que notre
optique c'était maintenir bien sûr les
plateformes leur permettent de
fonctionner donc
j'accepte un certain degrés de
flexibilité mais en même temps garantir
le droit du travail et le droit des
travailleurs qui travaillent pour ou sur
les plateformes donc nous avons eu une
consultation aussi des partenaires
sociaux c'est prévu d'entrée donc c'est
une consultation à deux étages et j'ai
eu plusieurs reprises y compris une fois
à Paris une
des réunions avec des travailleurs des
plateformes qui m'ont fait part
d'ailleurs des conditions de travail
souvent difficiles
auxquelles auxquelles ils sont
confrontés donc voilà le la manière dont
on a travaillé je ne peux pas dire que
on a écouté les plateformes il y a un
certain nombre de plateformes n'est pas
la majorité c'est une minorité qui
soutiennent la directive la simple
raison que il pratique finalement des
contrats de travail ils embauchent les
salariés et ils veulent en quelque sorte
ne pas se confronter à une concurrence
déloyale de se des plateformes qui
finalement ne restent pas le droit du
travail et c'est effectivement de
d'opérer avec
avec un niveau de protection et de et de
coûts sociales si je peux m'exprimer
ainsi le plus bas possible mon dernier
mot c'est un mot sur la valorisation du
travail j'entends beaucoup qu'il faut
une discussion sur la valorisation du
travail qu'il faut mettre fin aussi à la
précarisation du travail et c'est un
souci qui m'anime beaucoup
dans le contexte actuel pour covid mais
aussi dans le contexte actuel de pénurie
finalement de travailleurs dans beaucoup
de de domaines et donc il y a un domaine
où la pénalité et précarisation du
travail et quand même largement répandu
c'est au niveau des plateformes et donc
il faut encadrer ces plateformes qui
sont nés
grâce à des nouvelles technologies grâce
à l'intelligence artificielle et donc on
ne peut pas baser le développement de je
dirais le progrès technologique en
l'associant d'un côté à la régression
sociale et c'est avec cet esprit que
nous avons fait
que nous avons présenté cette directive
que j'espère
adopter avant la fin de la législature
du du président Parlement européen
merci beaucoup monsieur pour cette
exposé très intéressante et très complet
moi je suis juste je vais vous demander
vous avez mentionné à la Californie bien
sûr c'est un des modèles dont on a parlé
dans cette commission d'enquête quand
vous regardez ce que vous essayez avec
le Parlement les États membres de bâtir
avec cette directive est-ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui au sein de l'Union
européenne ou ailleurs des pays qui vous
paraissent être des modèles des exemples
en tout cas assez en avance dans
l'équilibre à trouver entre le
fonctionnement des plateformes et les
droits qui sont réservés aux
travailleurs de ces plateformes
il est clair que un certain nombre
quelques pays en fait ont adopté
législation il s'agit notamment de
l'Espagne qui ont adopté maintenant une
législation sur les plateformes j'ai
encore récemment eu un échange avec un
ministre espagnol en lui demandant
est-ce que vous constatez en quelque
sorte une régression de l'activité des
plateformes
c'est évidemment pas le cas alors il y a
des plateformes qui disent bon sous ce
régime parce qu'ils ont grosso modo la
loi espagnol ressemble beaucoup à ce
qu'on a fait dans dans notre proposition
directive on voit que certaines
plateformes se développent d'autres
pensent que c'est pas le modèle qui leur
convient et se retire du marché espagnol
mais globalement la quantité de
plateforme est la même ou le nom de
personne qui qui travaille pour les très
fort ou du moins le nombre d'heures
travaillées pour les plateformes reste
le même ou voir est en augmentation
étant donné que la demande sur le marché
et et croissante donc l'idée de dire si
vous encadrez mieux les plateformes si
vous reclassez convenablement justement
les travailleurs des plateformes qui
veut pas dire que il ne puisse pas y
avoir des indépendants sur les
plateformes mais le seul critère c'est
que d'abord ça doit être accepté par le
la personne et deuxièmement il faut que
les règles qui s'appliquent aux
indépendants soit les règles de
l'indépendance et non pas d'un faux
indépendant en fait d'un salarié qui est
considéré comme l'indépendant avec le
seul but d'économiser les cotisations
sociales ou autres ou autres règles donc
je dirais que oui il y a des états où
c'est appliqué
c'est vrai qu'en Allemagne la plupart
des plateformes sont obligées
d'embaucher sous un contrat de travail
et ça veut pas dire que l'économie des
plateformes ce soit rouler
il y a aussi maintenant je constate
qu'il y a de nouvelles formes qui
apparaissent vraiment des coopératives
notamment j'ai eu un échange récemment
avec
des des personnes à Paris qui veulent
constituer une coopérative qui
fonctionne un peu comme les plateformes
de transport mais sous forme de
coopératives donc je pense que il y a
beaucoup de modèles qui à la fois
peuvent combiner les droits sociaux avec
avec les avantages flexibilité
la proximité avec la demande du
consommateur
qui représente des plateformes
merci beaucoup et juste une autre
question de mon côté je voudrais savoir
quel regard vous portez sur la version
amendée du Parlement européen de la
directive et en particulier sur la
question de retirer les critères de
requalification est-ce que ça vous
paraît être une une piste d'atterrissage
possible ou ça
entrave selon vous le bon fonctionnement
de de ce qu'on essaie de faire avec
cette directive
le Parlement
a opté pour une approche un peu
différent pas fondamentalement différent
mais il parle de la présomption générale
que tous ceux qui travaillent pour une
plateforme sont effectivement des
des salariés et c'est après quand il
s'agit de reclasser qui font intervenir
des critères et donc il y a un acte de
reclassement
dans notre approche le reclassement se
fait une fois que la présomption est
confirmée donc c'est un peu une
différence d'optique bon je
ne vous cache pas que je préfère la
proposition de la Commission et ça c'est
normal mais
je pense aussi que à la fin compromise
fera plutôt sur la base de ce que
propose la commission tout en peut-être
s'inspirant de certains éléments
proposés par le Parlement voilà
merci beaucoup Monsieur le Commissaire
européen à l'emploi et aux droits
sociaux je pense que le débat que nous
avons là était un débat extrêmement
important et pour notre commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur l'aspect les
conséquences et les droits à apporter et
à apporter c'est une question centrale
que celle du statut des travailleurs des
plateformes
de l'ubérisation en tous les cas de la
plateformeisation du travail bon peu
importe les termes que l'on emploie si
on est bien d'accord sur ce qu'on y met
dedans parce qu'on va bien qu'on assiste
depuis une décennie à une stratégie
extrêmement agressive à travers ses
plateformes pour pouvoir casser dans
tous les États membres et dans le monde
entier d'ailleurs les acquis conquis de
haut lutte concernant le droit du
travail le droit des travailleurs des
travailleurs et les droits sociaux
afférents les systèmes de protection
sociale et que leur volonté c'est bien
en contournant de revenir ou tâcherons
des 19e siècle donc
cet enjeu législatif et fondamental
essentiel
j'ai le sentiment que les plateformes
sont très vite rendu compte et Hubert en
premier mais d'autres avec elle que elle
perdait toutes les décisions
toutes les démarches en justice et que
toutes les démarches en justice
quasiment en tout cas dans une grande
majorité majorité
concluait que les travailleurs des
plateformes pour la plupart étaient bien
dans des rapports de subordination et de
voir leur statut requalifiée en salariés
et je pense que les travaux législatifs
que vous avez engagés sont aussi
issus directement de cette contact
constatation
de des décisions de justice dans les
différents États membres face à cela
Hubert en termes de lobbying à chercher
à défendre dans un premier temps à tiers
statut qui serait soi-disant ni
indépendant ni salarié
on ne peut que constater que peu de pays
ont suivi
dorénavant ils sont sur une autre
stratégie dites moi si vous confirmez un
peu si vous en avez aussi cette écho qui
serait de dire mais finalement par le
dialogue social faisant en sorte qu'il y
ait de nouveau droit pour les
travailleurs des plateformes et moyennes
en quoi à partir du moment où on obtient
de nouveau droit pour les travailleurs
les plateformes on l'exclut la
requalification salariée ce qui
finalement revient assez à un tiers
statut que pensez-vous de cette enfin
voyez-vous cette stratégie là des des
plateformes est-ce que lorsque vous avez
pu les les auditionner est-ce que ce
sont ces éléments qu'elles ont pu
défendre
oui j'ai comme je vous l'ai dit
un certain nombre d'échanges avec
différentes plateformes je crois qu'il
en avait une trentaine que j'ai
surtout avec lesquels j'ai discuté en
ligne parce que c'était un moment covid
mais j'ai rencontré le silo aussi du
Berre encore il y a pas si longtemps qui
a voulu précisément me convaincre de
l'approche que vous que vous évoquez
c'est de dire en quelques sortes vous
savez la possibilité tellement vitale
pour le fonctionnement d'une plateforme
mais on est bien sûr aussi favorable à
la protection de nos salariés mais
faites tout confiance
ça voudrait dire en fait en quelque
sorte et d'ailleurs je l'ai retrouvé
dans d'autres plateformes
nous on veut pas se
soumettre en quelque règles de du droit
du travail ni des règles de la
protection sociale on va assurer cela
nous-même à travers des formes de
dialogues sociales avec ceux qui
travaillent pour nous qui restent des
indépendants mais avec en quelque sorte
un statut un peu un peu ambigu donc
cette idée du personnel vous dira c'est
le troisième statut mais c'est une forme
de troisième statut bon je crois que il
y a une question très simple ou bien il
y a subordination il y en a pas ça c'est
le premier question s'il y a
subordination il y a il y a relation
salariale parce qu'on va pas maintenant
jeter aux orties à droite du travail qui
a été construit vous l'avez dit au fil
des des décennies voire plus pour plaire
donc la plateformes le grand danger de
tout cela c'est que ça ne va pas
s'arrêter aux plateformes et des livres
et autres ça va faire école parce que si
je trouve une voie pour échapper au
cotisations sociales parce que je vais
en partie privatiser cela etc bah je
vais le faire et ça ça ne va s'étendre à
plein de secteurs dans le secteur de la
santé dans le secteur la construction
dans le secteur de l'hôtellerie dans le
secteur de
du nettoyage aussi déjà très présente
donc on crée une sorte de salariat de
troisième zone avec moins de droits et
qui sont livrés à 100% vont vouloir au
nombre pour pouvoir de la plateforme
donc il faut absolument arrêter cela
parce que ça va avoir des conséquences
sociales d'abord pour une partie des
personnes qui travaillent et
deuxièmement ça va à terme poser un
énorme problème sur le système de
protection sociale parce que s'il y a
des banquiers de l'économie qui ne
cotisent plus ou différemment ou moins
et ben le problème du financement de nos
systèmes de protection sociale notamment
de la sécurité sociale va
très vite devenir extrêmement difficile
donc je crois que cette cette
présentation est une présentation
biaisée qui font pas accepter point
alors je je puisse soit l'ensemble de
vos propos j'ai le sentiment que la
France s'engage en cette voie là
en créant l'ARPE l'Autorité de
régulation des relations des
travailleurs des plateformes avec les
plateformes
ayant
alors une LARP a été mis en place avec
une participation aux élections
extrêmement faible des travailleurs des
plateformes et qui par ailleurs pour
l'instant ce cantonne au
transport et à la livraison alors que
comme vous le dites et on le constate en
France la plateformeisation ou
l'ubérisation se développe dans plein de
secteurs on a auditionné également par
cette commission d'enquête des
plateformes qui à un moment donné
interviennent dans la restauration ou
qui interviennent dans la santé il y a
plein d'autres secteurs confrontés
l'art a pu travailler sur
des accords concernant le prix minimum
d'une livraison ou le prix minimum d'une
course et on voit à quel point cela
conduit à une extrême forte précarité
dernièrement lors d'une France travail
le ministre du travail français monsieur
du soft
a pu répondre à des questions de députés
en disant que lui il défendait la
présomption d'indépendance donc la
strict opposition à la présomption la
position de présentation de salariat
défendue par la Commission et défendu
par par le Parlement européen
est-ce que il y a des interventions de
de la France à votre égard est-ce qu'il
y a eu des retours à posteriori
et qu'est-ce que vous pensez plus
globalement de la stratégie de la France
vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de la directive
est-ce que c'est une stratégie de
blocage au conseil nous sommes plusieurs
l'intégralité des groupes
parlementaires nupes de la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
ont demandé au nom de l'article 50
alinéa 1 de la Constitution française
qu'il y ait un débat à l'Assemblée
nationale autour de la position de la
France sur cette ce projet de directive
à présent sur le salariat et qui puisse
être assorti d'un vote avez-vous
connaissance de procédures démocratiques
équivalentes dans d'autres pays
européens le sujet est allemand étant
selon nous tellement central pour nous
c'est une nécessité qu'il puisse se
faire en toute transparence or pour
l'instant nous n'avons pas eu de débat
réel même si cette commission d'enquête
parlementaire lors de l'audition du
secrétaire général aux Affaires
européennes a pu enfin avoir accès aux
documents qui permettent de préciser la
position de la France mais sans cela il
n'y avait pas de véritable débats et
pour l'instant ça n'est pas un véritable
débat organisé au sein de du Parlement
français
bon je vous ai dit que la France dans
les discussions en cours
défend une position qui
qui notamment
fait pas d'une demande d'une dérogation
assez généralisée bon ce qui confirme un
peu ce que vous dites c'est une
présomption d'indépendance mais en fait
la présomption de la dépendance ça veut
dire que je donne raison a priori à la
plateforme parce que c'est ça parce que
quand je dis 90% des plateformes disent
mais mais mes partenaires appelons les
comme ça sont des indépendants
que ce sont des indépendants donc ça
revient maintenant au travailleur des
plateformes de montrer qu'il n'est pas
qui n'est pas
un indépendant la présomption c'est ce
qu'on a aujourd'hui et donc il faut
aller juridictions pour contester donc
précisément contenu du rapport de force
on a retourné un peu la situation et
c'est ça la présomption salariale basée
sur des critères et avec bien sûr une
possibilité pour la plateforme de
remettre en cause cela et de démontrer
qu'il s'agit en effet de
d'un statut d'indépendant donc
je ne veux pas commenter les positions
des états des uns et des autres il y a
d'autres États qui ont des réserves donc
la France c'est pas le seul autrement on
aurait déjà abouti à une solution et un
compromis mais il est clair que la
la position de dire il y a présomption
d'indépendance ça veut dire c'est le
statu quo il faut savoir c'est à la
limite pire que le statut quo donc ça la
commission bien sûr ne peut pas en tant
que tel l'accepter puisque pour nous
c'est précisément de sentir de ce statu
quo et en défaveur du travailleur des
plateformes et
précisément créer plus de clarté plus de
sécurité juridique qui n'existe pas à
l'heure actuelle
autrement comment comment
expliquer que dans les 300 jugements qui
ont été
prononcés par des cours
une extrême majorité sont toutes sont
tous allés dans le sens de la statue
salariale et je donne d'ailleurs
toujours l'exemple de Londres alors
Londres le Royaume-Uni n'est plus membre
de l'Union européenne il est pas connu
pour avoir un droit du travail
extrêmement strict ce sont plutôt des
protagonistes de relations du travail
très flexible pourtant la haute pour de
Londres à décider que les chauffeurs du
beurre pour rester avec cette plateforme
sont des salariés sont des travailleurs
et en droit un certain nombre
d'avantages salaires minimum congé etc
protection santé et est-ce que ça a mis
fin aux activités du beurre d'ailleurs
je vais dire aussi du beurre à Londres
non aujourd'hui Hubert occupe plus de
chauffeurs à Londres qu'avant donc cette
idée de dire on a besoin de cette
situation de la dépendance pour
maintenir en vie ce secteur pour garder
les emplois etc notamment dans des zones
peut-être frappés par le chômage c'est
ça n'est pas confirmé vraiment par les
faits je crois que s'il y a une demande
la demande est là et elle va elle va se
poursuivre quelle que soit en fin de
compte le statut qui qui sera mise en
place d'ailleurs je je m'a souvent
demandé aussi bon ça va coûter plus cher
parce que si il faut s'il faut payer les
cotisations sociales etc il faut payer
aussi une rétribution tout juste qui
serait alignée notamment sur le point
sur le salaire minimum et bien ou
éventuellement un contrat une convention
collective
ça va coûter plus cher oui peut-être ça
va coûter un peu plus cher mais en fin
de compte qui moi est-ce que c'est au
propre travailleur celui qui avec son
vélo ou sa voiture tourne des heures des
heures pour pour gagner vraiment très
petit est-ce que c'est à lui de payer le
prix d'un service je crois que le
service doit être etquitable le prix du
service doit être équitablement réparti
c'est-à-dire consommateurs y compris à
la plateforme parce que n'oublions pas
que les plateformes se servent aussi sur
le prix payé par le consommateur donc je
crois aussi que consciemment c'est une
question de justice de justice sociale
et de et de rétribution équitable d'un
service rendu et du travail
même je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président
alors moi j'aurais deux questions
premièrement j'aurais enfin il faut me
le confirmer mais ça vous l'avez dit en
vous expliquant c'est bien entendu une
présomption simple c'est à dire qu'on
pourra renverser facilement il n'y aura
voilà simple par rapport à la
présomption irréfragable ou mixte c'est
une présomption que je peux renverser
dès que j'ai la preuve contraire c'est
bien ça
voilà autre question est-ce que vous
pensez que le fait de mettre une
présomption donc de salariat va
forcément régler tous les problèmes
justement de
salaire très bas de est-ce que tous les
problèmes seront pour autant régler
est-ce que pour avoir une comment dire
pour pour que le salarié soit davantage
protégé ce qu'il ne faudrait pas aussi
avoir des conventions où on explique par
exemple parce que l'autre jour on avait
quelqu'un qu'on auditionné qui
expliquait qu'une course avait un
certain coût et que donc il faudrait
définir
dans le contrat que la plateforme ne
puisse pas rémunérer trop faiblement
quelqu'un est-ce que ça devrait passer
finalement
d'autres protections et notamment
d'imposer des règles en fait aux
plateformes quand elles embauchent dans
tel secteur des règles notamment pour la
rémunération je sais pas si j'ai été
très clair
effectivement de la mise en oeuvre de la
présomption que vous avez bien définie
du moment où la présomption est activée
et
la commission la personne est reclassée
évidemment la plateforme a le droit de
remettre cela en cause et de demander
effectivement le renversement le la
remise en cause du recrutement ça c'est
c'est nécessaire ça fait partie aussi
des règles des règles de droit mais une
fois que la personne est réglassée pour
me demander est-ce que la présomption va
régler le problème de la rémunération
d'une certaine manière du moment où la
présomption de reclassement est activée
et fonctionne la personne devient en
effet un salarié et du moment où la
personne devient salarié ce sont des
droits qui sont activés et le premier
droit et c'est effectivement
d'avoir droit au SMIC et donc sur les
heures que la personne travaille
la personne doit être au moins rémunéré
au SMIC sauf si il y a une convention
collective et ça effectivement
nous nous soutenons aussi cette approche
de la convention collective
convention collective qui prévoit un
salaire supérieur au SMIC donc je crois
au moins avec avec le statut du salariat
il y a la garantie d'avoir sur les
autres travailler le la rémunération
équivalente du SMIC
la Commission ne peut pas fixer dans une
directive des rémunérations ça c'est pas
possible nous n'avons pas d'ailleurs
légalement le droit de le faire et nous
ne pouvons pas le faire mais je crois
que du fait que on établit la
possibilité de reclassement en salariés
comporte un certain nombre de
conséquences qui du moins répondent un
peu à cette question de la très faible
rémunération il y a un aspect que je
n'ai pas mentionné et qui est celui des
indépendants des vrais la dépendance et
il y en a sûrement donc on veut pas
maintenant nier que il y a des personnes
qui veulent être indépendants qui
veulent travailler en tant
qu'indépendant avec tout ce que cela
comporte aussi en tant qu'indépendance
et
très longtemps jusqu'à présent les
indépendants ne pouvaient pas s'associer
je peux pas s'associer si par exemple
dans une plateforme il y a de vrais
indépendants vous pouvez pas s'associer
pour négocier la rémunération avec la
plateforme puisque c'était considéré
comme un cartel
au titre de
du droit de la concurrence européenne et
ben on a maintenant levé
cette cette
obstacle puisque on donne maintenant le
droit aux indépendants de s'associer et
des négocier le cas échéant avec une
plateforme
un contrat collectif et ça s'applique
aux vrais indépendants c'est-à-dire ceux
qui effectivement
ont les droits que les indépendants ont
c'est-à-dire ne sont pas subordonnés
comme des salariés
oui et donc c'est intéressant aussi
parce que comme vous le dites
effectivement certaines personnes ont
envie de rester indépendante et donc il
y aurait deux plateformes différentes
comment ça peut s'organiser puisqu'il y
a une présomption vous me direz à
l'activerez pas comment ça peut
justement en pratique
comment on peut à la fois dire qu'il y a
une présomption de salariat et à la fois
maintenir le statut d'indépendance pour
certains indépendants
les plateformes sont très différentes
c'est ça
oui
tout cela dépend à la de la relation que
la personne qui travaille avait ou pour
la plateforme qu'elle a au sens
juridique du terme si je suis un
dépendants un certain nombre de droits
par rapport à celui pour lequel je
presse des services qui ne sont pas
exactement les mêmes que quand je suis
salarié donc il est envisageable d'avoir
dans la même plateforme de statut
différents des gens qui sont de vrais
indépendants et de l'autre côté des gens
qui aujourd'hui sont placés indépendants
mais qui est des facto sont des salariés
puisque il y a une vraie relation de
subordination alors il reçoit les
instructions ils peuvent
ils n'ont aucun droit à déterminer le
niveau de rémunération
donc tout ce que ce qui est dans les
dans les dans les critères qu'on a
introduit dans dans la directive et qui
en quelque sorte définissent aussi une
relation de subordination
quand la Commission européenne a pu
procéder à un nombre de consultations
sur le projet de directive
les les plateformes dans leur lobbying
étaient très actives nous avons ici
auditionné la député européenne Leila
Chebbi
qui nous a nous a exposé à la fois le le
sentiment qu'elle avait de de de
le sentiment qu'elle avait et même le la
façon dont fut témoigner que les lobbys
se sentent souvent un peu chez eux dans
les institutions européennes
même si un encadrement du lobbying au
niveau européen elle dans son Mandal
s'est attachée à développer un lobbying
populaire afin de faire en sorte que les
travailleurs des plateformes puissent
s'auto-organiser et puissent se faire
entendre avez-vous le sentiment que
ce lobbying populaire sachant que vous
dans votre démarche vous avez aussi pris
l'initiative de rencontrer les d'écouter
les travailleurs et travailleuses des
plateformes avec vous le sentiment que
ce lobbying populaire a pu
agir modifier influencer le contenu du
projet directive en tous les cas
contrebalancer le lobbying des
plateformes c'est ma première question
et deuxième question je me permets de
relancer les questions que je vous ai
posé précédemment et auquel je trouve
que vous n'avez pas répondu
sur l'influence de la France pendant la
rédaction de la proposition directive ou
à posteriori qu'elle a été voilà qui a
été cette qu'elle a été telle et sur la
question démocratique est-ce que vous
avez connaissance d'autres Parlement
nationaux qui ont eu des débats dans le
cadre dans leur cadre sur la position de
leur pays en tant qu'État membre sur le
projet directive voilà est-ce que dans
d'autres pays il y a ce rapport-là
d'exigence démocratique ou pas
bon sur les l'écoute en général
vous citez une
bon il est normal qu'un commissaire
d'abord dialogue avec les députés
européens collectivement ou aussi
individuellement donc j'ai eu des
contacts avec un certain nombre de
députés européens y compris d'ailleurs
avec la rapporteur de du rapport initial
fait par le Parlement européen qui est
député française madame Brunet qui comme
j'avais dit déjà son rapport à tout à
fait dans le sens de notre projet
directive
et donc j'ai eu à Bruxelles comme j'ai
eu à Paris comme j'ai eu en line des
discussions aussi avec des travailleurs
des plateformes comme j'ai eu des
discussions avec
28 je crois 28
plateforme donc
c'est tout à fait normal et je ne
considère pas c'est du lobby c'est de
l'écoute parce que la Commission quand
elle fait une proposition elle ne fait
pas une proposition dans le vide il faut
écouter ceux qui à la fin sont impactés
par nos propositions alors ça valait
absolument c'était absolument le cas
évidemment pour les travailleurs des
plateformes comme c'est le cas des
plateformes donc on les a écoutés mais
en fin de compte on avait on est arrivé
à la conclusion que l'approche qu'on
proposait qu'on voulait proposer il
était d'ailleurs comme je lui ai dit
dans le rapport du Parlement européen à
savoir la présomption était la bonne
approche
et la bonne approche pour maintenir les
plateformes pour avoir plus de justice
plus de clarité plus de clarté plus de
sécurité juridique donc sur ce plan là
je crois que
jamais eu la pression que on faisait de
la pression sur moi j'écoutais et après
la Commission et vous savez c'est pas le
commissaire seul qui tire qui peut faire
une proposition c'est la le collège de
la commission c'est un travail collectif
à la fin une approbation collective et
il y a pas eu au collège des problèmes
sur sur la proposition qu'on a fait
alors est-ce qu'il y a eu des débats je
sais que il y a des débats dans les
parlements j'ai des échos il y a des
débats encore aujourd'hui on m'a fait
pas des débats qui ont eu lieu au
Parlement danois par exemple le Danemark
est très attaché à cette directive il y
a il y a manifestement eu des débats
puisqu'ils ont adopté une proposition
une proposition en Espagne il y a eu des
débats au Portugal il y a eu des débats
j'étais invité d'ailleurs par le
Parlement italien un peu comme vous le
faites aujourd'hui mais c'est moins
controversé peut-être avant
je vous l'ancien gouvernement avec le
ministre du Travail au débat de notre
directive avec les parlementaires
italiens donc il y a eu beaucoup aussi
dans les parlements nationaux j'ai eu
aussi un contact avec le d'ailleurs dire
avec le Sénat français je t'ai invité je
suis allé présenter la directive au
Sénat français donc je crois qu'il y a
eu dans plein de Parlement ce type de
départ
est-ce qu'il a eu des fausses je n'ai
pas vérifié et vous savez qu'il y a des
états ou finalement sur le plan de des
décisions européennes du Parlement
jouent un rôle très important mais ça
c'est une affaire interne dans lequel
dans laquelle je ne peux je ne veux plus
intervenir
bien merci Monsieur le Commissaire
européen je vous ai promis de vous
laisser partir presque à l'heure donc
nous avons quand même été un petit peu
en retard mais je veux vraiment vous
remercier infiniment pour la précision
de tous vos réponses sur ce débat qui en
effet absolument fondamental dans nos
démocratie et pour l'Union européenne et
que nous allons poursuivre au sein de
notre commission d'enquête merci
beaucoup de toutes ces précisions et de
votre disponibilité si nous avons des
questions complémentaires peut-être pour
nous voulait faire passer dans les
prochaines semaines et naturellement si
vous même il y a des éléments de
complément que vous voulez rajouter
n'hésitez pas à contacter notre
commission d'enquête qui continuera à
assiéger pour les deux prochains mois
mais l'intervalle je vous remercie
beaucoup de votre temps et je vous
souhaite monsieur commissaire une
excellente journée
merci beaucoup encore une fois c'est un
grand auteur et la Commission est
toujours disponible disponible et
disposé à dialoguer avec les parlements
nationaux donc je suis à votre
disposition merci